mejor Maribel Comencemos con un poco de
contexto Cuál era la importancia de esta
Represa de no baja coca
hace más de 60 años fue construida con
el fin por un lado pues de dar
proveeduría de millones de millones de
litros a más de cinco millones de
ucranianos también da proveeduría a una
planta hidroeléctrica esta central que
requiere grandes cantidades de agua para
ser enfriada y por lo tanto es una presa
que es totalmente importante en la
región puesto que desde noviembre del
año pasado Ángela estaba ya en el ojo
del huracán como una ofensiva militar
rusa pero también por el lado de
defenderla del lado de Ucrania por este
gran impacto que hoy sin duda está
ocupando los titulares a nivel
internacional Ángela aribel hablando de
lo inmediato Cuáles podrían ser las
principales consecuencias tras esta
destrucción las inundaciones las
afectaciones al medio ambiente las
crisis potenciales para crimea y para
para Rusia y Ucrania
Así es Ángela se habla ya de un posible
ecocidio es decir un desastre al medio
ambiente sin precedentes también esto
impulsaría lamentablemente que hubiera
desplazados de un más de 24 provincias
de la región también estaríamos viendo
que pues sería un un arma estratégica
por parte de Rusia para seguir avanzando
que si ya de por sí tenía control de la
región de gersón pues entonces ahora
decir que por culpa de Ucrania ahora
crimea te queda sin abastecimiento de
agua lo cual pues es terrible para la
población de crimea puesto que depende
de este recurso y no olvidemos Ángela
que esto será Justo a la luz que entre
el día de ayer y hoy ha llegado el
enviado especial del Papa a Ucrania en
aras de hablar sobre un posible acuerdo
de paz
por otro lado parece difícil pensar que
la destrucción de La Represa suponga un
beneficio para alguna de las partes en
el conflicto para usted este hecho es un
acto terrorista ruso como dice Ucrania o
un acto de Sabotaje para desviar una
fallida contra ofensiva como dice Moscú
me parece que es un acto como lo hemos
venido viendo desde hace más de año
cuatro meses que es atacar a las
infraestructuras estratégicas para
debilitar a Ucrania y aunque ahorita en
este escenario ya no tenemos la realidad
Clara de si en verdad fueron las tropas
rusas y fueron las tropas ucranianas
como bien lo dices ninguna de las dos
partes saldría ganando al contrario los
ataques a infraestructuras estratégicas
lo único que hace pues es debilitar
ambos bandos pero me parece que esto es
el resultado de esta nueva campaña
ucraniana que se habla de una estrategia
de silencio no decir por parte de la
milicia ucraniana las estrategias porque
lo que se sabe el día de hoy Ángela Es
que hay una contraofensiva ucraniana
pero no se tiene mayor información a
manera de estrategia militar por parte
del gobierno de Ucrania Así que
estaremos seguramente las próximas horas
atentos a ver qué más información hay
para que quede claro Cuáles son los
daños reales y estas imágenes que dan la
vuelta al mundo en redes sociales se
dice que en realidad son de noviembre
del año pasado y que no corresponden a a
estas últimas horas Así que hay mucha
información en torno a esto por lo tanto
tenemos que seguir muy atentos aquí en
rock 24 para ver cuáles son las
actualizaciones de esta noticia